[Music]
hello I'm Adrian finigan and this is
counting the cost on Al jazer a Slowdown
in international trade soaring debt
levels High inflation and high interest
rates what lies ahead for the global
economy in
24 but China is grappling with deflation
as prices continue to fall how will
slowing growth and demand there affect
the rest of the world and the economic
impact of Israel's war on Gaza even as
oil prices haven't been affected
concerns amounting about shipping
[Music]
costs a global recession was widely
predicted in 2023 but major economies
have mostly held firm raising interest
rates to control inflation
the US economy expanded by 5.2% in the
third quarter the quickest Pace in
nearly 2 years food and fuel prices have
come down but inflation and high
interest rates remain a major issue in
many parts of the world we have a panel
to discuss the global economic outlook
for 2024 in a moment but first a report
from prianka
gupto holding interest rates steady the
US Federal Reserve signals it's done
with hikes at its last meeting of the
year in December since March 2022 it's
raised rates 11 times to ease inflation
which is now slowing after hitting a
40-year high in January
2022 at its final meeting the European
Central Bank followed the fed's lead
leaving rates
unchanged But Central Bankers are
warning it would be premature to declare
victory over
inflation we are seeing uh you know
strong growth that is that is appears to
be moderating we're seeing a labor
market that that is coming back into
balance by so many measures and we're
seeing inflation making real progress
these are the things we've been wanting
to see we can't know uh we still have a
ways to go while large parts of the
world are worried about inflation China
has the opposite problem deflation
prices are falling with domestic demand
weakened by high youth unemployment and
a property crisis and there's the
rhetoric from Washington about
decoupling its economy from Beijing the
international monetary fund is warning
of fragmentation into power blocks
centered around the US and China risk
wiping trillions of dollars from Global
output China is no longer the largest
trading partner to the US and its share
of us Imports have fallen by almost 10
percentage points in 5 years from 22% in
2018 to 133% in the first half of this
year the trade restrictions imposed
since the onset of the US China trade
tensions in
2018 have effectively curbed Chinese
Imports of tariffed products faltering
demand from China has prevented oil
prices from rising despite concerns
about a broader conflict in the Middle
East and US oil production is at a
record high limiting the impact of
production cuts by OPEC plus
exporters 2023 has been a year of
economic surprises defying predictions
of a global recession while central
banks explore interest interest rate
Cuts in the months ahead geopolitical
conflicts and elections in key economies
bring additional uncertainty to
2024 prianka Gupta
alaz well let's break down the main
economic trends for 2024 now with our
three guests from London we're joined by
Charlie Robertson Charlie is the head of
macro strategy at uh fim Partners as
well as the author of the time traveling
Economist from Miami Florida we're
joined by Shirley Shirley's senior
practitioner fellow at the Harvard
Kennedy School and from Doha we're
joined by Ahmed Halal Ahmed is practice
director of the Middle East and North
Africa region at Global Council welcome
uh to you all Charlie let's start with
you a worldwide recession uh had been
widely predicted by economists in
2023 and as we were hearing a few
minutes ago uh the US economy grew at
its fastest Pace in nearly two years
what happened
well uh I mean as as as a time traveling
Economist perhaps I was paying too much
attention to history we hadn't seen rate
hikes like this for decades uh not since
the early 90s and it was just a the
Assumption was that had to break things
um and when we saw Silicon Valley Bank
blow up in March you know people began
to think that that was exactly what was
happening but I think we underestimated
two or three things firstly the the the
Biden fiscal package Biden's fiscal
boost to the economy helped secondly
Americans were all on 30-year fixed rate
mortgages which they they've remortgaged
or got those mortgages at the lowest
ever rates in 40 years in their careers
and and very few have had to take on new
mortgages um even as rates went up they
they stuck with those fixes that really
helped and then thirdly all those covid
payments uh and that cash support in
2020 and 2021 just lasted longer than
than I think most people expected
Shirley what lessons then can be drawn
for
2024 uh from I mean I think it's fairly
safe to say the surprise economic
developments of
2023 I like the way you frame it uh just
now the gentleman mentioned about fiscal
stimulus in the United States and I
think that is the lesson that can be
trans uh transpired uh to the Chinese
economy in 2024 as well empo fiscal
policy stimulus has been put in place to
advance China's infrastructure
development in 2024 and I think it's
very likely that uh the fiscal deficit
for 204 is going to break the 3% uh
threshold and so uh 2024 is likely to be
a infrastructure boom year for China not
only in public infrastructure but also
uh in affordable housing development
projects in China's urban areas
meanwhile the Chinese government will
continue to pump billions of dollars
into the uh strategic technological
sectors from semiconductors to AI to EVS
Etc so in looking at China's uh fiscal
stimulus I think um you know that uh
over time is going to create jobs and
jobs will boost the market confidence
and when confidence restores somewhat
that'll help uh to support uh consumer
spending and therefore the economy will
pick up from there a what about emerging
economies the bricks Nations uh will
countries like uh Brazil uh and and
India play a much bigger role in the
global economy going
forward well both are increasing in
geopolitical significance India just
hosted the G20 and Brazil will now host
the presidency of the G20 Brazil and
India are both top 10 Global economies
um Brazil is an emerging Energy power as
well and will be trying to benefit from
the next round of the super commodity
cycle and increase in Energy prices as
when D Silva Lula D Silva was in power
earlier uh when he benefited from high
oil prices India particularly
geopolitically is becoming a
counterweight to China and you find
Western Powers the US Europe trying
their hardest to uh uh strengthen ties
with India as a counter way to China we
saw this in the feud uh with Canada over
the murder of a seik activist um in
Canada and the West didn't have very
vocal responses to um to that incident
uh on climate action as well you see
Brazil wanting to be a more EnV a more
responsible Environmental uh Steward and
wanting to use the bricks and the
expansion of the bricks to forward that
agenda Charlie what's going to happen
with inflation this year gaze into your
crystal ball for us is it going to
continue to fall are uh central banks
going to be able to to ease
rates my base case is that it is going
to fall and the Market's very much on on
track with that but I I think China and
and what your previous speaker was was
mentioning is a part of that story
China's real estate problems are so cute
and so likely to be so prolonged that I
think China is going to try and export
its way out of its recession and that
means it's going to be exporting
deflation so we've already seen it going
out and buying iron or in a big way to
overproduce Steel which is now getting
dumped on the global markets it's become
the world's biggest car exporter in the
world that's giving us lower prices for
electric vehicles so I think they're
going to be exporting deflation to the
rest of the world and that's going to
help get uh get inflation down all right
we we'll we'll talk more about China
specifically in just a few moments but
what's the outlook for uh Europe where
um economic growth has been well pretty
stagnant hasn't it over the last
year yeah and I think the markets I
think what we're all having to recognize
that the Europeans have made a tradeoff
and they said we have to cut our energy
dependence on on Putin we can no longer
trust the man um and that has carried a
cost and that cost has been born largely
by German industry and German
manufacturing which doesn't have the
cheap energy Supply from Russia it used
to have and and we're seeing terrible
iPhone numbers there will be an
adjustment and the fact that energy
prices have fallen so much in the last
just in the last month or two tells us
that that actually this could almost be
self-correcting the globally lower
energy prices therefore help German
manufacturing start to get back on track
through 2024 but uh yeah Europe is
looking weak as as we enter 2024 surely
you you heard Charlie they're saying
that that China is going to export
deflation what can it do to to stem uh
this trend of falling
prices well China has been exporting
deflation to uh particularly the Western
Market and the rest of the world pretty
much for the past four decades so there
is nothing new there but one thing that
was highlighted uh which is interesting
is actually the lingering uncertainty
surrounding China's really State market
and of course uh the banks uh have been
trying to offer even uh on some
occasions un collateralize the loans to
Chinese real estate developers in order
to arrest the real estate market decline
however in the central government uh uh
economic work conference that happened
recently um real estate was not even
mentioned so we are still looking at a
fairly painful year ahead for the
Chinese real estate market yeah what
what what what specifically is going
wrong with with China's real estate
market we've been talking about this for
quite some time now on on counting the
cost uh and the government doesn't seem
to be able to do anything to to to
revive
it well if you were to look at the
global experiences uh in the recent
decades uh the realistic cyclicality
happened both in Japan in the 1990s and
also in the United States in the early
20 uh 21st century so in looking at from
Peak to 12 for the real estate C it took
Japan 13 years to reach uh the bottom of
the real estate cycle and it took the us
about 5 years from 2007 to 2012 uh in
Japan's case from 1990 all the way to
2003 so it does take a long time uh once
the real estate Bubble Burst uh for the
market and particularly the market
confidence to recover so in the Chinese
instance if you were to look at the real
estate market Trend the Chinese real
estate Crisis happen on a more severe uh
uh uh scale both in terms of scale and
the size in comparison to the Japanese
uh real estate bubble burst in 1990
however uh what made the difference
between the Japanese uh situation versus
the United States is the government
response because in 2007 the US
governments uh resorted to this all what
can do attitude uh including four rounds
of quantitative easing so that the the
uh the recession uh were able to recover
fairly quickly uh and by comparison the
Japanese uh Central bank's uh uh stance
uh was rather uh I would say hesitant at
the point in time so really how long
it's going to take for the Chinese real
estate market to recover uh to a large
extent also depends on the Chinese uh
Central government's uh monetary and the
fiscal policy support aad what's what's
your view on how China's economic woes
uh will affect the rest of us in
2024 well it's the second largest
economy in in the world so if you look
at the Middle East the China gets most
of its oil and gas uh least oil from
from from the region so that's a clear
negative for countries that depend
overwhelmingly on oil Revenue to power
their economy so the market fundamentals
now with Supply outstripping demand is a
clear negative for the Middle East and
that will depress investment
domestically and um uh lead to Greater
voluntary cuts from OPEC production OPEC
producers Charlie there's been a lot of
talk in the US about decoupling the
economy uh from China's is is that
happening in practice
now no no it's really not um and despite
all of the efforts the the trade deficit
with China remains massive and I think
it's going to be an increasing issue
both with Europe and with the states um
but I just would like to touch on that
last question also about the Gulf but
what's interesting about what we're
seeing out of Saudi and UAE is like
India we're seeing this big boost into
infrastructure um and that
infrastructure investment boom also
talked about on CH for China is is part
of of Saudi trying to diversify its
economy it's a trillion dollar economy
it's actually playing it's one of the
growth stories at the moment and they
can afford to leverage up their balance
sheet um through the 2020s to help that
diversification even if oil prices are a
bit lower we'll come on to oil prices in
just a minute but first I I I I want to
finish with with China Shirley uh what's
the future for China's belt and Road
initiative given that the the only major
uh Western member Italy uh has pulled
out uh more precisely the G7 member uh
indeed that is a pivotal change uh
however um the Bon Road uh conference uh
that happened recently announced an
additional 100 trillion dollars of
incremental lending facilities to the
developing countries I think the balom
road uh initiative will continue but
it'll fundamentally change its
characterization going forward one uh
the balom road initiative will become
more Nimble and more selective in terms
of projects I think renewable energy
development in the developing World
particularly in Asia and Africa uh in
the Middle East uh will continue to play
a dominant role in its uh p future
policy framework um China has uh
initiated this small and beautiful uh
essentially Nimble uh solar energy
development projects in Africa and if
you were to look at China's access uh
capacity in solar wind Hydro EVS Etc uh
it it has a global dominant position
China owns roughly about 70% of the
global Solar Supply Chain over 50% of
the global wind supply chain and so um
the global uh renewable energy
transition will not be able to uh be
achieved without China's supply chain
support and two I think China will
continue to focus on a lot of strategic
projects that are uh that are uh Central
to its national security so for example
China recently expressed the support for
a new landbridge project in Thailand
that will essentially create a uh
pathway uh as an alternative to oil
shipping route across the state of Mala
so the state of Mala has traditionally
been considered a a strategic
vulnerability for China and apad what
what's your view on on the growing um
relationship the Strategic Partnerships
we're seeing between China uh and middle
eastern
states well it's increasing their
technological partnership it was mainly
a relationship of importing and
exporting oil but they want to move up
the technology value chain they want to
diversify their economies and China has
been investing in infrastructure is part
of the Belton Road initiative in in the
Gulf in the Middle East broadly in Egypt
as well uh but increasingly they want to
corporate on things like U AI
semiconductors Automotive the renewable
energy industry so there is a greater
integration on on areas other than
hydrocarbon so you will be seeing China
you have high level visits uh from
sheing P earlier this year and
reciprocated by trip the by MBS so there
there is greater engagement between to
the two countries and areas outside
energy okay let's let's talk further
about oil uh prices had risen in the
initial days of the of Israel's war on
on Gaza uh out of fears that it could
spark a wider Middle East conflict uh
since then uh prices have have fallen um
what does that mean for the global
economy well it's it it's about uh
Market fundamentals it's about
increasing Supply and Records m in
Supply from the United States in the
Shale patches peran Basin um from
non-cartel non OPEC members increasing
their production Brazil uh Guana and you
have uh weakened demand so waning demand
at the same time from China and Europe
um lower o oil price prices are are good
for manufacturing sector for energy
intensive sectors um in in Europe but
there are other drags on on global
growth as my colleague earlier was was
was saying uh High interest rates and
higher costs are weighing on on growth
generally and of course China's private
property sector and its own economic Wes
are growing are are weighing on uh oil
demand so that's why uh we haven't seen
the Gaza War have a real uh impact on
oil prices and it's also that market
participants have have assumed that it's
going to continue to be a localized uh
conflict a contained conflict that will
not be widening and will not be
affecting um the global uh uh trade
flows and Global energy flows and and
Ahmed can can OPEC OPEC plus do anything
to stem uh the fall in in the price of
oil or at least the stagnation of
it it doesn't seem to be working I mean
they they keep uh increasing their Cuts
their voluntary cuts the uh in September
Saudi and Russia as part of the OPEC
plus group U reduced their production by
million barrels per day at least Saudi
did Russia followed suits but it doesn't
seem to be working because the the cuts
are being offset by uh this um massive
increase in um and this this goes as
Testament to the resilience of the US
Shale industry and US oil and gas
production that they whenever they've
been written off they come back and
they're now producing the US is the
preeminent oil oil producer around 20
million barrels a day uh compared to
Saudi which is on average 11 or 12
million barrels a day and U these Cuts
in an attempt to prop up the price are
actually reducing the market share of uh
Saudi and its OPEC uh uh OPEC peers um
so uh it's it's not looking good in
terms of uh oil prices and fiscal
receipts for the gulf oil producers at
market share Charlie is high us oil
production Now The New
Normal it took a little while to come
through um I think the Shale guys were
particularly cautious um after Co not to
overproduce and create a slump um but
yeah it looks it looks like this is
sustainable and it's going to carry off
sometime but what will change is global
demand so Global demand as interest
rates come down because lower oil will
bring down inflation central banks can
then deliver rate Cuts that'll help on
the demand side and it's going to save a
lot of countries countries like Pakistan
Kenya that have been facing acute debt
issues uh are now going to find life an
awful lot easier with low oil prices so
I I think this is coming at a fantastic
time for the world economy actually
Shirley to to what extent is is China's
uh slow slow down impacting upon those
those falling oil
prices China is the world's largest
energy importer so China's slowing
economy obviously will cast uncertainty
and the future shocks uh not only to
Global oil prices but also to the other
Commodities including IR ore Etc and if
you have noticed recently because of uh
the lack of consumer confidence in China
um Chinese have been buying a lot of
gold uh pushing the Chinese domestic
gold prices at 10 to 15% premium to the
global market price so uh obviously
China is going to have a huge impact to
the global commodi uh supply chain but
uh um as previously mentioned it would
be unrealistic to think of a full
economic decoupling between the United
States and China however um that's not
to say that it's not going to be a
painful process as the uh you know the
US China decoupling happens uh primarily
in the technology supply chain and uh
including increasingly in the uh
investment sectors so say for example in
semiconductors uh us semiconductor
companies from Nvidia to qualcom Intel
Etc they all have a huge market share uh
in China in in the's case possibly
around 25% of its Global Revenue comes
from China so now you have us
semiconductor companies that are looking
for a comparable Market the size of
China's and there is just simply none
out there meanwhile Chinese companies
have the money but there are just simply
things uh out there that Chinese cannot
buy so you are looking at both the
buyers and sellers and every uh other uh
you know essentially operators along the
supply chain are are going going through
a rather painful process for quite a
long time all right finally I want to
touch on on shipping costs aad what's
the impact of of the poy attacks on uh
ships passing through the Red Sea uh
that we've seen on uh shipping costs and
how concerned is the industry about the
the bab El mandab
straight um of course it's increasing
Insurance costs increasing the
geopolitical risk premium for uh
Charters and and and Freight industry um
the bub and mandab and straight of
hormos actually straight of hormos is
even more important as as as an oil
choke point 25% of global Seaborn oil
trade transits to straight of foremost
and the B is little less about 10% of
global oil trade so they're key Global
oil archeries and the the hoi attacks a
Spate of them have been happening since
the outbreak of hostilities between
Hamas and Israel but they were happening
before that and uh they haven't really
been moving the oil price if you believe
the oil price today at $73 a barrel um
you you you see that that the market has
priced in these incidents and the market
believes that the the conflict will
remain contained will not be widening
and that these incidents will not really
be uh moving the dial of course if if
there is escalation if there if there
are retaliatory strikes retaliatory
strikes from Israel on Iranian
infrastructure Iran oil refineries and
the stet of horal is blocked or
disrupted for any for any reason then we
could see some very extreme scenarios
with the price of oil the World Bank
anticipated perhaps going up to 1557
dollar barrels a dollars a barrel which
would be
a huge oil shock and would be a dual oil
price shock with Russia and Ukraine
still happening okay there I'm afraid we
must end it many thanks indeed to you
all Charlie Robertson Shelley U and
Ahmed Halal and that is our show for
this week if you'd like to comment on
anything that you've seen you can get in
touch with us on X I'm at a finegan
there please try to remember the # ajcc
when you do or you can drop us a line
counting the cost at al.net is our email
address as always there's plenty more
for you online at al.com CC that takes
you straight to our page which has
individual reports links and entire
episodes for you to catch up on but
that's it for this edition of counting
the cost in Doha I'm Adrian finigan from
the whole team here thanks for being
with us the news on outter era is
[Music]
next